our voicemail number is 2192 David P and
you can call that voicemail number
anytime here is a viewer who
unfortunately like many of my viewers
and listeners is really confused about
my view of the democratic party take a
listen
great
let me do or not regard this message
explains that we have the Democrats are
so great yeah higher gas prices
uh unemployment at an all-time high
I can see the naming of why I told the
borders come on man wake up yeah so
listen first of all almost nothing this
guy said is true open borders border
policy is almost completely unchanged
from Trump to Biden almost completely
unchanged record high unemployment we
have records low unemployment record low
unemployment mid threes we are
essentially at full employment
high gas prices gas prices are down
dramatically
uh and really they have very little to
do with the president of the United
States I didn't blame Trump when gas
prices went up and I didn't praise Trump
when gas prices went down I didn't blame
Biden when gas prices went up and I
didn't praise Biden when gas prices went
down it really doesn't have much to do
with the president at all but maybe the
most important confusion that this
caller has is I don't say the Democratic
party is so great
not even a Democrat again my view is
that the Democratic party is an
organization whose main goal is to
preserve its own existence preserve its
own existence I don't care about the
party at all to the extent that in any
particular race the better candidate is
a Democrat I'll vote for the Democrat
that's as far as my allegiance goes to
any political party and so this is not a
show where I say vote blue no matter who
or the Democratic party is great or
whatever the case may be this is a show
where I say I don't care about political
party I'm not a member of any political
party I evaluate candidates for their
policy and for their platforms and I
decide who closely or more closely
aligns with me sometimes it really is an
option of bad and less bad and I choose
the less bad option I think most
reasonable people would and sometimes
there are actual Democratic can that
it's that I like and I I sort of
willingly and gladly vote for as well
but uh please criticize me for things I
actually say not things you imagine I
said we have a great bonus show for you
today we are going to talk about this
wacky Dr Oz story uh where experiments
research he was involved in reportedly
led to the deaths of more than 300 dogs
the story is a little more complicated
than the headlines make it out to be
which is why I'm glad to have the
opportunity on the bonus show to discuss
it California Democratic governor Gavin
Newsom who is a potential 2024 uh
presidential Contender has signed a bill
decriminalizing most jaywalking in
California who cares right jaywalking is
actually a tool that is used to
criminalize and to create a pretext for
interactions between police and citizens
and residents and uh it's actually a
really important bill we're going to
talk about why and the onion the
satirical publication defends its right
to parody in a very a real supreme court
brief relating to a satirist this is
also a re you know when these folks on
the right talk about free speech
um they really are talking about free
speech of a certain type
for certain people
they claim it's about all free speech
but it's really not this is a really
interesting case actually about Free
Speech all of those stories and more
coming up today on the bonus show thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
Dave Pacman well I have the pleasure of
hosting the bonus show every single day
you can sign up at joinpakman.com become
a member and we will see you on the
bonus show in just a moment otherwise
we'll be back tomorrow with a brand new
program